mommy right and I got nowhere the big
house just the [ __ ] working on
acidophilic gay [ __ ] a [ __ ] camera
[ __ ] lighting like you got a phone he
ain't gotta be up in the hostage jurat
rabid wolf it accomplished most of the
ownership and leverage safety and
protect us out there beverage
hey everybody mon-monday
tractor running Tuesday morning headed
to LaGuardia Airport at the Kansas City
for a meeting with potential client all
day and flying right back home that
classic 7:00 a.m. to midnight day we're
going to them now any microwave super
well and really focusing a family time
is maybe notice trying to I try to at
some time to settle with them so I'm
sure if I'm gonna pull off a vlog every
day but start counting the content love
the reaction from our
last couple episodes so make sure if you
are missed
wait last week last three or four or
five you had a lot of stuff in them but
the Memorial Day weekend threw up a lot
of people so check it hope your super
well let's see what happens today
he rocks up for something I could speak
my knowledge for like four years
embarking game with my third degree
that's got itself checking now so now
house see your looks like a Roman made
he'll read this is my month now why you
understand it dropping but then is may
not into rings my shooters like Oliver
elf with the still it's just what I feel
ain't too many can outtalk demand they
like what I married they started to
bother sold out the mess I carry bees
like what the [ __ ] you go need a Roger
where they left in yo I'm not impressed
I need to keep it real [ __ ] your
corporate meetings I don't need to deal
a speaker oh [ __ ] and nothing else made
it right here I did it by myself
get a lead to messy end up they should
stay around a wedge or for the face of
snow it kotas with the lyrics know when
the Candice we don't care what you are
pitching everybody trying to be on you
see a movement wanna grab in a row all
you've got to do is drop it with a
product disc so never sing how he does
I'll get what you're doing by using why
your songs where you going place up lift
up tonight and then make a call my
fantasy situation has not gone well and
I'm not happy about it but I'm happy
about this whole iPhone episode really
think I think it's cool I like I just
switched it
what is the iPhone episode literally
just all shot as I heard
oh actually I really didn't notice that
until just now like that it's just a new
look for you oh yeah yeah
getting back to the basics a little bit
lighter yeah it's gonna be part of like
an ad for Apple than daily be shot on I
shall show them that if Android wants to
Samsung call me through Vogel pixel for
the shell my or whatever yeah being a
hardcore asian company with lots of
zeros you know that we can be sold on so
many different players and you a sponsor
daily the episode just from a business
case study state appointment
I'm just like wearing like this I
actually believe that a product
integration is going to be inevitable
because as you're just taking too much
time away and I think that's where it's
all going
it's what the influence a team is an
essentially just like a more basic level
chase reddit AMA podcast is getting
ridiculous responsible so if you want
big things you have to be able to take
the risk of wasting your time because
the upside is if tomorrow
snapchat comes out with a feature that
crushes it and gets super hot again
everybody who jumped off of snapchat
because answered a story very sad if you
if you haven't signed up for my podcast
do that right now here's the link and
definitely definitely definitely watch
the ugh listen excuse me this reddit AMA
I'm going to put up the video Tim
there's more beyond believe you Friday
and it just came out today I did a
reddit AMA I filmed it okay so that come
on team they're really cool I am Yo no
Yo no Yo family no I'm getting no a nice
day today
like we just have to get out of micro
analyzation Wow being empathetic that
that's what everybody has to do and not
to do it's kind of like my mom model
right which is like pure offense but
don't put yourself out of business I'm
pathetic you know bringing up a
historical one doesn't only have so many
MS aesthetic to it but it needs to be
talked about and brought to me versus
slow and friction we have to figure that
out it comes before we get nimble with
all the extra assets we have so I think
you should actually spend time on that
yeah let me already yeah that to me is
an interesting conversation because if I
can rank these type of things 1 through
37 then we can work backwards because I
can give you a lead because my
salesmanship will be right oh yes ok
what you doing like behind while you're
talking where you going
hi stop I have Yo no Yo no y'all family
don't get it
very nice better day anyway yeah we're
hanging me up on wasn't me you wrap a
sound like I left it in sunny day I mean
you want my son's the West mine still
but I'm gonna let it spin down for back
when hip-hop was what a [ __ ] talk for
some average gets accomplished friends
watch the screen jean-jacques and act
like hard workers cos it's 3 o'clock and
they stay awake mediocre songs as they
slave away
we ain't impressing those here to stay i
know you hear my words to get the press
back everybody ain't made they thought
the children they seen who spoke slow
rise so my parents we go back like the
jordan post i may be hearing no I'm
never leaving
let's come up into play this track it
was a girl girl when you [ __ ] in bed
it's try to start me up spend a half
rescission what sport appear at the
airport just got like six internal phone
calls done structure operations a little
bit of strategy for we're going some key
hires that are on their way
couple key client decisions new product
offering sitting delayed here to Newark
after I had a flight canceled to
LaGuardia and I'm six calls moving other
calls Tyler and I are just texting back
and forth so it's kind of living hustle
entrepreneur like Lodi walk around the
capture everything and just a you know
very much focused on this thought of
people's lack of willingness of risking
their time as it's valuable some of the
couple episodes ago it's a go thing
that's super on my mind which is how are
you so scared to do things on spec free
works Trident platforms when your time
is invaluable
you're not crushing it you're not making
tons of money the amount of view that
are beggars as I said and are acting
like choosers
Loes my mind the I call it ego you know
one thing I'm proud of
I've ridiculous amounts of ego I'm
[ __ ] fired up I think I'm the greatest
in my actions I deployed Basak you
Millie
I'm always going to do shows that comes
here in campus videos back at this point
in my career and a bunch of you just
aren't willing to put in the work like
your [ __ ] fancy to like your [ __ ]
special with your [ __ ] LeBron or
Barack or [ __ ] okay
I just don't get it just what it really
I do get it actually you're just [ __ ]
full of [ __ ] you're not going to put in
the work and so you've decided that
you're you're you're too fancy to try
new apps because what if it doesn't get
big you don't enough time to make
Instagram and snapchat stories you don't
have time to make somebody a design or a
piece of content for free like you're
something special
everybody's [ __ ] special
I kill people to think they're special
try to stop me ups better half position
was forty balls with 20/20 vision
there's after worse but I've got twice
the views of Mike hood murders I never
made it no never seen oh he does okay
just Lam Newark ran in to make their
connections I'm running to go make four
more phone calls today you know just a
classic day trip to Kansas City you know
being mom she's just kind of grinding it
out for one really well with the clients
got a lot Donuts email I like the travel
days because you know two three four
five six hours of email time really the
only time I do my email or catch up on
my actual work is when I fly so the days
are a little bit more efficient than
people think a lot of people ask me why
don't I fly private all the time is the
time valuable the answer is of course
other than the fact that I actually need
the two to four hours of email to get my
[ __ ] done so a really good way to start
the post Memorial Day weekend feel very
accomplished feel like I got a Monday
and Tuesday in on this Tuesday
now I'm gonna go take this piss finally
first time I'm seeing it in the wild
what up Gary
hey Gary incredible we have so many
tools we're still goddamn lucky face I
know no you and I are doing a Drivetime
radio show right now that would have
cost millions of dollars to distribute
just 20 years ago [ __ ] a [ __ ] camera
[ __ ] lighting like you've got a phone
underfunded everybody is reading my
books and watching everything and
reading everybody's motivated
everybody's ordering the equipment it's
what you love only scared that all my
followers are you ever see that guy who
like fives Roger Federer sneakers and
wristbands and he's got an $800 racket
and he's got the headband and the water
bottle and he drinks the $8 [ __ ]
electrolytes coconut water and he
stretches for 15 minutes and then he
goes on the court and uses 6-love here
that's what I'm scared of
what winners do which is put in the
practice I want you to take some tennis
ball and hit it against the wall because
that's all you've got a shitty racket
and your wall and you just keep hitting
it over and over and over again
[Music]
[Music]